i was talking to somebody today
and i said and i said and which is true
okay
which this is this is a fact i said
listen
trump lowered his uh unemployment for
hispanics
and blacks lowest in history but it's
only by a certain percentage
also now you're gonna marginalize wins
so 44 other presidents have never done
it but this man did oh but it's only by
a little bit
so people's reasoning for voting for
biden
when you literally sit there and look at
the policies look at his history look at
what he's done
when you look at and you realize that
trump is beating his ass
and every pretty much every other
president of ronald reagan ronald reagan
in the past 44 presidents you have to
start to rationalize
why you're voting for a certain person
because if you look at the policies and
then you look at the reality and you
look at
everything overall trump is the best
choice over biden
and he depends on the policy though
depends on what the
the majority of the like if you if
you're a gen xer and your number one
priority is climate change
right and you have a candidate who
basically thinks it's so which policy
would trump do you like the least
which policy do i like with trump let me
get off which one do you like the least
look uh uh here's here's one here's one
that i th with with biden i would have
thought about it right off the bat i can
tell you
i can tell you right now i don't like
for the president to make the military
in this country feel compromised
and that is why mattis came out publicly
and said what
see i i disagree i don't you think he's
making the military you don't think he
has full support of the military
i do i i think the negativity there's so
many generals
saying general stanley mcchrystal a
major army
uh veteran just came out and said
there's no way i can vote for this
person oh my christmas this is
not obama crystal is an obama guy
mcchrystal
the gentleman we just had general
matters that's a different story
generally his chief of staff
just came out two weeks ago and said
this is the worst person i've ever
turned out there was some more personal
things between those two it wasn't a
black and white scenario
mattis was interviewed right before the
corona virus and said as long as he's a
sitting president
i will not say one negative word about
trump
you cannot ask me again when we
interviewed him as well because maybe
maybe trump disrespected him behind
closed doors that's never happened
it wasn't that he said in his op-ed
exactly why he'd come out against first
of all
danielle here's that's a completely
different conversation
to me completely different conversation
mattis
married the military true mattis was in
love with a girl
and he decided to say i'm never going to
get married because my wife
is the military mattis has got a show on
hbo's three episodes four episodes where
you watch this episode by the time
you're done with you're thinking this is
like general patton napoleon and all
these guys combined in one human being
and you just enjoy watching this and god
bless america i'm all for madison i'm
team mattis i'm a hundred percent
100 but but sometimes when you got these
two bad mo fo alpha guys
there is no way mattis can report to
did either i mean would add it up is it
seven or eight
deferments between the two candidates
yeah but you know what
military performance to not serve the
country you added up between those two
guys
who was willing to die for america
you're more confident that biden's going
to do more for military than trump no i
didn't i did not
say that you said what bothers you the
most that has nothing to do with how i
feel about you
in our military about policy what policy
of biden
do you love the most and what policy of
trump does that's an easy answer it's
the headline on the newspaper right now
healthcare
true health healthcare is your number
one trump has been saying
you for the last three months i've
talked to you you've never brought up
healthcare now we talked about it
tonight it was the number one issue
for you your number one reason why
you're not going to do trump is
healthcare i've never brought it up
before
it just happened now wasn't it not a big
factor it just happened now
it just happened now so the point he's
making is right with you
i fully understand what you're saying
danielle i agree with you
because where you're coming from i'm a
maddest guy i'm the guy that says
you got to listen to him mattis here's a
guy what are you doing not listening to
a guy like madison are you kidding me
everybody in the military respect
i'm an army guy he's a marine guy he
saluted him we spoke the first time i
said
we look up we brought him to the company
to speak and we had a marine interview
him
and he's not a trump guy so we're very
comfortable doing something like that
but
the question he asked is if somebody
who's in the middle
you said what it looks like on tv i do
agree
which a big part of voting is what
people are seeing on tv
and i sometimes wonder and i said or
social media whatever
if we took out right now social media
okay
it is 1964.
first debate that was nixon kennedy okay
on tv you know
you know which one i'm talking about i
don't know what the year is the sweat
the sweat right
the sweat if we have no tv if the only
if we have the first tv we have but not
as crazy
like you know the way the media is
manipulating today it was overall to
cronkite star more people were
if we don't have that these two faced
off with each other
and the principles they're both selling
based on what america was founded on
there is no
all the other stuff that we have going
on who would be
crushing the other one based on the uh
policies that they have
it wouldn't even be close based on the
first debate it would definitely be
close based on tonight's debate
it would have been trump yeah it's not
even close and i'm not even talking
about personalities
i'm purely talking policies trump's
personality
there's a book i read called barbarians
to bureaucrats he says in
every great company and society and
organization there's what
there's a dreamer yeah there's a prophet
uh there no no
there's there's a oh that's right that's
right uh what's the
there's a no he says there's a dreamer
there's a
engineer and there's a son of a [ __ ]
right yes you
have to have a son but you've got to
have it
and that guy is an absolute qualified
son of a [ __ ] and got people like that
sometimes but the president doesn't have
to be the side i actually don't mind it
i don't mind it listen i do not mind it
especially with tough issues man you
know a guy a guy who's a democrat i was
watching this video today he
gave a message 1.2 million views
in like two days and he says i'm not a
trump guy he says you guys got to
realize i didn't vote for trump
when the first time around he says but i
got to tell you he says in
any other season trump would be a
terrible president
a terrible candidate a terrible person
to run america
he says before today he is the perfect
person
for america today a sitting democrat
yeah you should
i was expecting today he said because
today there are so many people that are
trying to
leech and take stuff from america
because america's been able to
give up side deals to china for decades
and decades and decades
and america is the one that's allowed
china to go from a top 20
to top 10 to top five to not competing
number two fighting for first place
he says the only person that can go
against somebody like that
is only a guy like that nobody else can
pull it off right and he's the only guy
that's the chinese
so i don't know if he's right or not but
that part of it for me and what makes us
weaker
than than not standing up to china
that trump has done signing in socialism
like being
an agreement going on national
television yesterday morning and saying
that nancy's
bill wasn't big enough i'm sorry but i
don't disagree with you there we're on
the same but again if if he continues to
run up our national debt to the extent
that he is that makes us extreme that
makes him more vulnerable
than any rhetorical war with china he
needs to focus on our national debt and
on semi-conductors
not soybeans he needs to understand that
the chinese have already moved on to the
next step
he can't do that but the leader of our
the leader of our country has to do that
you and i are not going to agree with
them you and i are not going to agree
with them
here's how the situation works here's
how this thing works
okay first let's create a massive crisis
what's a massive crisis let's shut down
every state
let's shut them down okay let's
let's force trump to do a lot of cases
[ __ ] okay we'll do a lot of cases let's
get everybody tested then trump does uh
testing we have a million cases
well you just told me do cases i listen
to you
million cases yeah cases but it's not
three five percent people dying it's one
percent
and even if you go deeper it's point one
percent because the people that are not
getting it
it's not the three to five percent you
were saying yeah but they are the same
puppet masters
controlling the entire world here's what
happened so he doesn't have control
to get all these governors that are
shutting down their states he can't go
on so you can't do that
they're shutting down their states
they're they're begging for something to
happen
then their purpose is strategy think
about it let me go to the strategy and
tell me i'm wrong
here's what he's not going to do what's
he not gonna do we're gonna say
these people are struggling how dare you
not pass a stimulus
he's not gonna say yes to it because
remember what he said under obama
then they come up with a stimulus he
said yes then they're like oh
[ __ ] everybody starts making money
everybody's happy again economy is okay
it's doing a little bit better
10.4 million jobs back 11 million jobs
back say it again he won't do the second
time
he did it again so he played their game
against them he played their game
against them
and has he put has he created any jobs
with all of the money that our country
is spent
are we are we repairing our bridges are
we repairing our tunnels unfortunately
unfortunately unfortunately he did not
have an alternative
my opinion unfortunately danielle in a
situation
like that i i am i am
so with you on the stimulus i'm the guy
that was way i sat in the meeting with
david herzog the cfo of aig with bob ben
moshe won the greatest president in the
history of business that saved aig
he took 183 billion from the government
gave it back with 21 billion dollars
and then he died three years later from
cancer was on steroids the entire time
tilted agm never paid it back i'm all
about some of these big guys going out
of business
i fully get if you're not responsible
with the money that's capitalism i fully
am with it i'm on the same page with you
and yet he's barking like a seal at what
the federal reserve is doing and
printing money and keeping all the
biggest companies in business
you can if i if he doesn't do it say he
doesn't do it okay let's just say he
doesn't do it
let's go there actually go there for a
second
let's say he can't control the shutdown
media and the governors are saying we're
gonna shut down
let's say he doesn't do stimulus you
take me there he doesn't do stimulation
what did he just say uh up on the stage
he just said to biden
sometimes you got to talk him into it
right
mcconnell's people can push through the
the extension of the ppp
why can't he talk his his his gop
sometimes you got to talk him into it
into extending what small
bit the small business relief program
that the money's sitting there
that's not congress he doesn't have
congress daniel but he just said he did
he said sometimes you have to talk about
what i'm saying to you is actually let's
go there please
go with me okay it is me do you remember
me
he's not going to do stimulus it's not
going to stimulus and i'm sitting around
right here
okay and when i walk my dogs danielle
when i walk my dogs i never carry a gun
right before the stimulus happened and
the economy was in shambles
and people were firing people left and
right and it was very ugly remember
there was a moment in may was very scary
i walked my dogs with a gun in my hand
when i'm walking around i walked in with
my hand i hear right i had my gun right
then i was
when i was sleeping i was ready if
somebody comes to my house i'm ready the
reason why
the country's more ready now if if we
didn't do the stimulus
forget about the rights and protesting
america would have been
in shambles we would have had civil war
taking place and what's our national
debt going to be if we continue every
six months to put a three trillion
dollar band-aid on this
and don't create jobs you corner me as a
leader if you corner me as a leader
if you corner me as a leader and you you
have control over the media i don't
if you tell everybody everyone's dying i
can't control that
he has more control over the media
through his twitter
there's the other one that o'reilly's on
here's a guy that's from california
average about 200 here's a guy from
california here's a guy that's
living in california my plan was to go
back to california
i told everybody what did i say i'm
going right afterwards i said i'm going
to california
we're going to build the headquarters of
italy california or greenwich these are
two places we're looking at we're going
to go to new york
the moment i saw how newsome handled
california i said there's no way i'm
going to california
trump cannot do nothing to newsom even
trump cannot say
open disneyland with some real
you know comprehensive way to make it
safe for everybody
test them do anything i make no excuses
because he already has the
the florida blueprint that shows how
they can reopen
why he had that proof in hand and still
keeps people out of jail
i i think i think they fully play the
card and one thing that i
one thing that i said and i sit down and
i'm like simpson why is this guy doing
the stimulus every time i went back to
doing the stimulus
if he doesn't do the stimulus you know
we're sitting right here
windows all this stuff if he didn't do
the stimulus
you would have seen the craziest things
happen the next 60 days
you can't tell me as an american human
being you cannot go to work and i'm not
sending you money
it would have been civil war at the
highest level you would have seen the
distance
for a while i have to ask you a question
then
[Music]
if trump loses during his
lame duck does he extend the cdc
protection for
risk moratoriums for for rental
moratoriums rental eviction moratoriums
or does he left all hell breaks he wins
or does he let
no no i said if he loses is he going to
extend the rental eviction moratorium
until congress reconvenes and they can
pass stimulus and prevent
millions of american families with
families
these are not individuals these are
these are single moms with kids
from being evicted you know what he's
going to do you know what he's going to
do
because of his personality he's going to
let the whole ship burn what do you
think
he's going to do he's going to burn it
down okay i don't disagree i'm not
sitting here saying oh he's
not going to do it he's going to say
yeah okay but then democrats are going
to come and they're going to give it to
him the next
you know and you can't you cannot unwind
an eviction
you can't do it no i i guess that's why
people are armed to the teeth
yeah but that's there's a different
reason why he would be doing that it's a
different reason why
if you move if you make this move and
you make this move and i'm getting
cornered
if you corner me i'm sorry i don't know
if you corner any human being in a
situation
like this that doesn't matter why is he
getting cornered if he loses the
election legitimately
that's a different conversation what i'm
talking about don't know and i agree
with you okay
i just told her well he would burn the
ship down because he lost no he wouldn't
burn the ship down he just would say
that the renting we're not coming we're
not covering i i i don't think he would
burn the ship down no
i don't think he would burn the ship
down but yeah i'm saying to you guys
guys we cannot
and none of this is right there's no
morality about this 48
of landlords in america are small
business owners they're getting hosed
they're not covered at all and in
california it's even worse